we've been working on an intuitive
description of the natural response of
an lc circuit and in the last video we
got everything set up and now we're
ready to close the switch
let's close our switch
and now our switch is closed again
and what happens
well we had v naught we had some voltage
on our capacitor and that means now we
have some voltage on our inductor
that's what the switch closing did so so
all of a sudden our inductor had finds
itself with some voltage across it so
let's look at this equation here the
inductor equation and it says that
v naught that's the starting voltage for
from the capacitor that we borrowed
is l times the slope of the current
all right so now we have a finite
voltage
and then and we have a finite value on l
and that means that d i dt is some
number
and if we put positive charge up here we
know that v naught is positive
so let's sketch that
let's start a sketch of what
what's going on here
we're going to plot together on the same
plot the current in blue and we'll put
the voltage in orange
and this is the time axis here
so let's go back and check what was our
voltage when we started our voltage was
v naught when the switch closed
so i'll mark that out
and what was the current when we started
the current was zero so here's a
a zero current
down here
and now we're going to sketch in what we
think happens right after the switch
closes so we decided that there was
going to be
some kind of a d i d t
d i d t
equals
v naught over l
so there's going to be some i'm just
going to sketch this in there's going to
be some
rising slope there's going to be some
positive slope on the current
all right so we took our first step
now the other thing that's happening
here is that q what is q doing let's
track our our charge
q is actually going to start flowing out
of this guy this is the current that
we're talking about didt this is a
finite current and that current is made
of the charge that's in the capacitor so
that current starts flowing around
and running around to the bottom side of
the capacitor
right that means the amount of charge on
the top is going down
which means that the voltage is going
down so let's sketch in some voltage the
voltage is going to start going down
because the charge is leaving the
capacitor
all right so far so good
so let's keep going back and forth
between the inductor and capacitor and
see how these the voltage and current
changes
and the way we do that is we just look
at our the equation we had now
the
the voltage on the inductor is not v
naught anymore it's changed to
d i dt
equals whatever v is
over l
and we notice that v went down a little
bit so that means what that means the
slope of the current went down a little
bit
so let me make a little shallower
version of the slope here
all right
now what happened next to the voltage
a little more charge is left
has left the capacitor
headed over to the opposite plate so the
voltage is going to continue to go down
so now we're just we're just going to
edge forward
a moment to moment and see what happens
every time the voltage goes down the
slope of the current gets a little
shallower
right and then the voltage continues to
drop because the current's leaving
and eventually
that voltage is going to reach zero
and at the point the voltage reads zero
the slope of the current
is
zero the slope of the current is zero so
right when this happens
this
the slope of the current is zero
now the value of the current is some
some number
all right so now we have now we have
some value of current we have a zero
voltage now when we have zero voltage
let's go back up here when this value of
voltage is zero here when this guy is
zero that means that q is zero and what
that means is that the
the charge on either side of the
capacitor is equalized the same charge
exists on the top and the bottom of the
capacitor
that's what this means here
so in our next moment what's going to
happen next
does the voltage go flat does it go flat
sideways does it go up does it go down
what does it do what does the current do
let's figure it out
so i see we have we have a finite
current okay what that means is that
charge is continuing to flow in what
direction in this direction here charge
is continuing to flow
like this and what's happening now is
we're getting excess plus charges
flowing on this side of the capacitor
so we're actually building a positive
charge on the bottom plate of the
capacitor and what that means is the
charge is reversed so the voltage is
reversed
and that tells us
that we're going to have a negative
voltage it's going to start to grow here
i have a negative voltage i go back to
my inductor equation this value of v
right here this is now negative so that
means the di dt has a negative slope and
a negative slope looks like it's sloping
down like this
it starts to roll over and slope
down and
a little less less current
means a little less slope on the voltage
now this positive current is going to
continue to keep flowing it's going to
continue to deliver charge to the bottom
edge to the bottom plate of the
capacitor
at some point that current will actually
go through zero again
and if we look at this situation
this is where we started from this is
almost the situation we started in
there's zero current
and there's a
this time it's a negative voltage we
started at a high voltage and we went to
a negative voltage this voltage here
happens to be
minus v naught
and the reason is is that all the charge
that was on the top now has made a trip
all the way around to the bottom so the
situation is perfectly reversed from
when we started
now because of that symmetry we're not
going to make this video any longer i'm
just going to say that this situation
will repeat itself basically
the voltage will curl back down like
that
and the current
will do this
oops let's just keep sketching in
so we've repeated the same story that we
did at the beginning part of the curve
over here just with the voltage sign
reversed
and now we reach another state
now we have
zero volts and we have a negative
current
here
and what we look at is we've duplicated
this situation here
just with the opposite sign of the
current there's positive
current and here's the zero voltage
now we have zero voltage and a negative
current so the whole story i told over
here is going to be in reverse this
charge now is going to reverse direction
let's take out all our arrows
and all the charge we had is going to
start flowing back around this way
like that this positive charge that we
had is going to flow around and meet up
with the negative charge that we
accumulated up here
and that's what happens that's what's
going on in this part of the of the
cycle
and we can continue on basically this is
going to go the same exact story
like that
and this will the current
will do the same and we've again we've
come back to the same exact point as the
starting point now we've replicated our
starting point
so what's going to happen next well what
happens next is the same thing that
happened in the beginning and this curve
actually repeats itself
as
long as we let this circuit sit here
like this
so we don't have to continue with the
story it's basically a repetition of
everything that happened here and what
we're going to get is a rocking motion
on the voltage back and forth and we're
going to get a a rocking motion on the
current back and forth
as these
as these uh energy storage elements
change
storage charge for energy in the
magnetic field and back to stored charge
and then it rocks back and forth
like that
so this is our intuitive explanation of
what happens in an lc circuit when we
let it do its natural response there'll
be this rocking motion back and forth
and now in the next video we're going to
go through and see how this comes out
mathematically